more than a decade after the matrix WB
continues to put faith in the Wachowskis
that no other studio has 40 seconds of
logos that basically assassinated the
DreamWorks logo fisherwoman took the
clowns for their own technically
speaking I'm an alien
Bella continues an air raid outside of
the Twilight movies my mother fell in
love with him and she found him almost
frozen to death oh this guy looks pretty
comfortable to me he neither looks
frozen nor near-death oceanus Kostka
tonight the Scott is completely full of
miracles including changing my Russian
into English after one sentence
for my dead body the old neighborhood
Cupid which inevitably means one of you
is going to die and she'll be named
Jupiter and just because it ends up
being the dad dying doesn't make it a
satisfying twist my mother pushed
everyone except her sister out of her
life some were in the middle of the
Atlantic she pushed me out to look what
a horrible analogy comparing the
figurative pushing people out of her
life with literal travel birth if I
bought a ticket to this movie I'd be
asking for a double refund already was
it Jupiter rising at twenty-three
degrees ascendant roll credits this is
supposed to mean that I am destined for
great things
and that I will find the one true love
of my life you know after dating a few
people here and there and finally
settling down like most people really
own day you think Macaulay Culkin is the
guy then it's Ashton Kutcher I wish it
had been natalie portman but beggars
can't be choosers
is this movie really making a futuristic
Cinderella reference meanwhile in Asgard
Eddie Redmayne walks through a green
screen in hopes that doesn't cause the
Academy to vacate his Oscar win two
weeks later also the theory of
everything states that when you go to
other planets everything will look fake
as hate my life
Mila Kunis provides movie reviewers with
their reviews opening lot I find it
immensely disheartening and unbelievable
that this Russian family that cleans
people's houses for a living never once
thought damn Jupiter is fine we should
try to get her to model maybe make tons
of money movie steals the Cleaning girl
wonders what it's like to wear a rich
people's clothes thing from made in
Manhattan wait is this entire movie made
in Manhattan and why the why no
made Manhattan well enough to even write
this discount purple haired female
Batman he was a sky check but you know
though the boots yeah but how does she
see that we see this guy has a magic eye
and this guy's face looks like a trip to
the moon but how does she see the boots
if you can turn invisible why would
there be a need to go back to visible in
this case Cain's weapons and stuff are
really cool but then this
can see nearly renders it meaningless
when also it's a confusing editing also
nobody in Chicago sees this that's him
spots of me we should warn lord balem so
this is one of those movies cram as many
characters and character names into the
first 15 minutes and expect everyone to
remember them play a little bit of the
pronoun game someone took this script
and said yes this is totally not
confusing after reading and rereading at
123 times greenlight meanwhile in the
boo ah Eagle cat face dude is Eagle cat
faced meanwhile in crematoria you know
when you watch a movie when you're eight
years old and you think the effects are
great and then you watch that same movie
20 years later and realize they weren't
great at all
yeah it's already 20 years later for
Jupiter ascending not crossed the
vastness of space for your pleasantries
mr. Nobbs hmm man what was Eddie
Redmayne going for here because he has
succeeded now I want mr. Neary found and
I want a dad awesome who the is
that again I'm getting way more John
Carter vibe here than I think the
Wachowski is we're hoping for you want
my advice yes why just a review there is
no reason to turn visible at this point
right and did these assholes show up
right after Jupiter went into the closet
thereby not knowing about her at all
amazing convenience Jupiter sets herself
up for 15,000 fake comments on YouTube
also of course mom calls when you're
recording aliens and your phone ring is
the loudest alien attracting ring ever
oh good more characters a whole table
full is probably the reason you are not
married men do not like smart women at
racist will be introduces Jupiter's
interest in astronomy all the sudden I
mean could you have at least shown her
looking longingly up into the night sky
just once in this movie before pimping
eBay okay my telescope dreams are
important enough to agree to whatever
your stupid plan is because telescope
Mila Kunis simulates what guys sound
like when they see Mila Kunis
unfortunately if she ever shows this to
anyone it will look exactly like someone
photoshopped a bunch of aliens into the
picture if you saw this would you be
like ah aliens or would you be like why
did you take a picture of Mars Attacks
it's her good killer aliens have
watchdogs employed at the clinic for
some reason but during the entire time
Jupiter's been alive they've apparently
never been employed at a hospital or
gynecologists office that would've aided
in their search also did they not bother
to check who she was back at the other
tricks apartment when she was taking
pictures of them it came to this was
happening today why did he wait until
the last minute he must have waited so
she believed his bulk story later
without it he's just a kidnapper
discount Channing - holy Sh
what the did they do to him shameless
cane wise do we have to put up with this
pg-13 mostly clothes floating orgy
we received an FTL from mr. wise what
does FTL stand for let's speculate
flaccid transportation leg you freaking
treacherous Lagoon College its to hear
that their planet is not the only
inhabited planet in the verse so lots of
new names for things but we'll just call
the universe the verse it's a name that
sounds like aliens made it up while
texting each other or they've been
speaking to mal Reynolds those things
it's a climb up keepers employ there for
some reason even though their only
purpose on earth appears to be to find
you what else were they looking for down
here meanwhile in Barsoom super bog Ruby
does itself no favors by reminding me of
the Super Mario Brothers film go let's
try and figure out why this movie bomb
I'm thinking it might have been the elf
ears lower Balin ship show up at exactly
the moment Cain and Jupiter are taking a
gravity elevator to a ship you woulda
thought he would've done this already
considering how important it is but he
let her sleep for 12 hours instead see
Chicago getting destroyed by attacking
aliens shots of the action from inside
office buildings tons of CGI this movie
is Transformers Dark of the Moon this
guy shows up announces aliens are real
and Foom lasers so bunch of
chase scene before we've even had a
chance to get to know Jupiter I care
less about this than I did the opening
credits let's try and figure out why
this movie bombed I'm thinking it might
have been the laser skates oh good idea
nobody innocent could possibly get
killed from this and this looks like a
very expensive piece of it's at this
point a million Mila Kunis's would be
recording this fight on their phones
from somewhere and speaking of a million
Mila Kunis's I like my odds in that
scenario also Kane is going to give us
some nuclear Bulls about how the aliens
can cover all the tracks after an attack
like this but we're talking about a huge
city with tons of eyes and cameras and
how could being it for your story that
somehow nobody's going to remember or
believe it when it's open when a five
minute chase feels like it's been going
on thirty minutes you've done up
also how slow is the military response
time to the aerial destruction of
Chicago Kane intentionally destroys his
own ship in order to destroy the enemy
ship which seems like maybe the
stupidest piece of strategy ever because
I just need to know what in the hell is
going on Milas initial table read
comments somehow makes it into the
shooting script those buildings will be
rebuilt by tonight
impossible take a look buildings just
happened to undergo instant rebuilding
right at the moment Kane says they will
be but don't you think there would be
cameras trained on the smoking than
non-smoking Willis Tower at this point
would be on CNN which means millions
more people are seeing this also how do
the aliens know how much stuff they
actually destroy during all that mess to
rebuild all of it did they keep track
they won't get everybody but no one ever
believes the ones that slip through the
cracks they cannot possibly know even
one person who saw all this much less
the thousands who saw it plus all the
different angles from iPhone videos to
completely cover the up also
reminder CNN Isis a victory Jupiter
ascending steals the why is this
happening to me from the matrix I can
guarantee you that slowing down this
footage would not give you the
opportunity to say this without a ton of
green lasers and flying around you at
some point during this long whiny
monologue how is it possible for a
single splice to destroy an entire liter
shadow fleet weren't there only like
five or six ship stops I call that a
squadron maybe a team but not a fleet
what is he doing living way out here
it's a marshal for the aegis Aegis
they're like cops this entire movie is
going to be devoted to exposition and
back story isn't it Sean Bean isn't
dying in this scene did we really need
this fight between Sean Bean and
Channing Tatum
I wouldn't Cain probably knows something
like this would happen and give him a
call before knocking on his door or does
he not have any way to communicate is
going on here the reaping also despite
the fact that these bees will definitely
not hurt her she doesn't know that and
Jupiter does not panic or run inside the
house to take cover why hasn't Jupiter
ever noticed anything weird like this
before
if she's the queen of Earth you'll
Majesty the universal signal for a
person of royal bloodline throughout the
galaxy shall be his or her ability to
control bees and so which shall be you
want your wings back or not he had wings
I just has no idea of the scientific
miracles that human beings are capable
of why won't those human beings share
things like this honestly this is not
the first question I would be asking
after I saw a bunch of bees coordinate
with my movements and someone just
called me your majesty
but sure let's get this burning question
out of the way first no bees are
genetically designed to recognize
royalty in children's books
please don't learn bees don't lie but he
just commands it one said gene prince is
verified what do you mean verified has
it not already been verified
like intently zip pack the sensor of
gravity this movie just took an
unfortunate turn for the Twilight also
you're literally saying this guy is a
lone wolf it's stupid when you say it
out loud like that so let's dress it up
a bit with a dramatic reading from Sean
Bean do you both have marks in your neck
but they're slightly different since
Jupiter woke up from the clinic battle
it's been a solid 20 minutes of
exposition it feels like they could have
made this where we get the answers to
these questions organically at the start
introduced Jupiter way later in the
movie in which he starts asking
questions you do a cross-dissolve
and she's like oh that's why everything
is the way it is then you don't have a
whole movie asking questions like this
are you saying your people kill the
dinosaurs spooby is a comedy right if
you had the ability to turn this craft
invisible you should have done it we
before 100 yards from the house stupid
idiot planet was seeded by abrasax
industry on being told his agent I want
to do a movie where I don't get to do
that much but I get to say a lot of
complicated technobabble expositional
lines and stuff with bees find me a
movie like that can you can you not
attack while you're invisible I ever
become visible why twice now they've run
into Kane with a shield and I guess
shooting at his legs it's not an option
I think King and shield is cool and all
but damn he's dead he's just wildly
throwing that thing and managing to
block all the shots not who is it the
lost world Jurassic Park wide come on in
and join the fun amazingly this ship
takes off with its hatch still open
giving Kane a chance to board the ship
before it leaves also do these ships not
alert you to extra weight when a
Channing Tatum jumps on it god dammit
meanwhile in the fifth element that's
tonight I think Eddie Redmayne took
acting tips for this movie from
Baltimore not ray Fiennes falta more its
you're better Jones wait a minute
there's something distinctly unsettling
about that name accessing memories from
my childhood oh yeah Jupiter Jones is
the name of the main character in the
Three Investigators books I can't wait
until she solves the mystery of the dead
man's riddle also Jupiter Jones this
movie did not miss one chance to up
not on Holi I guess on a list of things
to worry about on this planet fire is
just below unicorn breeding when the
exact same genes reappear in the exact
same order it is for us what you were
cool reincarnation
you mispronounce stupid he's some kind
of vampire race damnit Chomsky's really
like having their movies explained
vampire myths that is an oddly specific
and tiny thing to be obsessed with I
think but then look what I do for a
living so it's all relative I suppose
where do you get these light balls you
grab them what Chomsky's once again go
to the humans are resources for alien
life plot blindly hoping to recreate
that matrix magic I was told of the
house of abrasax seeded the earth will
be expects me not to laugh every time I
hear this name like a kid mispronouncing
the popular album from Santana this
assholes been skating all through this
place with no problem now suddenly there
are guard BOTS around as if in answer to
how ridiculous the non detection has
been so far let's try and figure out why
this movie bombed I'm still thinking it
might've been the laser skates canes
back has turned to two guards and they
don't bother shooting it I have more in
common with a dog that I have with you I
love dogs I've always loved dogs this
adds some disturbing subtext to this
romantic scene I love dogs movie thinks
that the main character repeats her
embarrassing line for a laugh it'll make
it all okay well I'm here to tell you it
doesn't asshole movie now thinks it's
some sort of modern-day Brazil which
undoubtedly means we're about to see
Terry Gilliam in the cameo being a good
sport about it almost four four minutes
of not hilarious space bureaucracy movie
is also liberally stealing from the
Akira Kurosawa film Akira but that will
be 63 years old and Japanese so who
could possibly have seen that fine film
yep Aaron's Terry Gilliam alright it
looks like he's being a good sport about
it I will never complain about the DMV
ever again it's 2015 people and many
DMVs are using modern technology to
automate the process let's come up with
a new cultural touchstone for waiting in
long lines I nominate Walmart he thinks
if we help you and you might help us get
back in the Legion I see good to know
what both lies it's pretty much no way
you heard that dude even with your super
Sean Bean hearing also Sean Bean is
playing a character who double crosses
the good guys cliche don't make this
harder than ask pain in a boners a boner
meanwhile in the dark a stir I am Titus
abrasax
stop stop please you're killing me you
are aware that by detaining me without
consent you are interact by lashing of
statue 27b stroke 6
I guess it's hilarious that she's
somehow learned they shouldn't well
being whisked through the bureaucratic
offices and everything but I'm calling
on it anyway there's only so
much leeway you get in the movie like
this futuristic prison cells are like
this
as saw the wardroom for the scene yet
still decided to go ahead and film it
they let him keep his laser skates on
when they threw him in prison
tis many names regenx ReCell nectar so
in the green it comes from people so
will it green you marry me
also I guess Jupiter never answers Titus
and they will soon part ways with their
mutual admiration of loose threads like
the lie you are now concocting that
somehow you survive being tossed into
the void
Titus steals the Bond villain way of
killing bond in every bond ever these
assholes keep his space
boots on when they send him out into the
void look guys I would won this any
child would won this it's like oh I see
you have your special flying boots on we
should remove those when you go into the
void so that you can't use them GLaDOS
put down in my schedule I'll be banging
hookers by 4:00 p.m.
Kane should be dead by then wait they
left a container of these life-saving
inste suits in the chute people into the
void room well he's running out of air
in the empty vastness of space I guess
it's time for an ex machina who just in
time
youichi and beast yes how many more
movies can we steal from let's try to
break a record yeah go ahead and shake a
little Hunger Games over this thing no
one's gonna notice oh you did not just
Pacific Rim this bitch too did you
god I could have come up with a higher
total for this movie by counting moments
it stole from other films instead of
sins scores upon scores of these
warhammer things and two tiny ships will
cut through them no problem sheer mass
should dictate that at least a hundred
more war hammers should go unscathed and
destroy Kane and stinger so movie does
not believe in math honestly this whole
thing is filled with so much screen
noise it barely registers as visual
information what's happening who knows
did you know there are antelopes called
dick dicks there are it's amazing this
is the slowest goddamn wedding ever and
I'm being constantly reminded of John
Carter it's the exact same movie give or
take a Taylor Kitsch but I believe
Taylor Kitsch and Channing Tatum were
the exact same person have you ever seen
them in the same room together no you
have it and a year from now both actors
will the played gambit think about it no
don't think about it tracking heavy sim
activity that's gotta be where shares
you mean there's a thing on your ship
that detects Sims you got to be kidding
me
the anti-aircraft guns on the ship
failed two anti-aircraft so seriously
there's nobody here except a bunch of
Sims no guards nobody who can take Kane
out why
care boy the world finds ways to hurt
you by that rationale this movie
should be giving me extreme pleasure
right now because I couldn't care less
wait they somehow knew she'd be coming
back home remember they kidnapped her
family just before the wedding
this would be awfully awkward if they
were just sitting here waiting for her
and she was either successfully married
or decided to stay with Kane in space
movie accidentally captures footage of
Eddie Redmayne being bored and keeps it
in the final edit I create guys that
line reading Kane is not properly
motivated until he hears the
inspirational Sean Bean speech nothing
again Sean Bean because he's awesome but
being suddenly motivated in this way is
like getting inspired by chappies cat
poster this Swiss Army torture device is
absolutely the most unnecessary thing
ever built I realize it might be hard to
watch a loved one die but this heroine
is about to sentence humanity at large
to death to save a few people so she's
an asshole and has obviously never seen
the wrath ACOG knew that I strongly
advise against this reckless course of
action that will almost certainly cost
you your life but captain he basically
took on all those war hammers and
anti-aircraft guns by himself earlier do
you think going through drew Pater's
Great Red Spot is going to do harm also
cane hits Jupiter's g-spot and it's a
treacherous experience subtext much and
this crash definitely won't kill him
either out of nowhere Kane shows up once
again unencumbered by even the minimum
of security yep definitely time for
kissing you're only in all the danger of
other titles this movie considered
guardians of the Riddick galaxy laser
skates and Jupiter's stupid just like
you won't bog chair in the midst of
trying to get gravity to decide this
this lizard thing flies right next to a
whatchamacallit Cain grabs the whatever
it is and breaks free by stabbing him
with the doodad cain't just wiped out an
entire squad of these things but this
one lone lizard dude is suddenly going
toe-to-toe with him for a really long
time simply because the movie is trying
to create tension and stretch the run
time ladies I'm gonna make
what hmm kill him already sorry and
sometimes say that when I'm suddenly
roused from sleep was i right this time
woman who scrub toilets all her life is
suddenly a badass action heroine and
this entire complex is breaking down and
exploding but keeps giving her ways to
survive an escape
look god damn it jupiter went in all
sorts of weird random directions running
from the destruction of this city she is
not running at a balaam right now
oh it's not she can't remember the
that you do I'm adding 25 sins for this
no 50 man this movie really went all in
on that laser skates idea and I gotta
say that was a very bad decision we have
very little time to get back to the ship
but sure let's land here in the middle
of the destruction to give you a rest or
something just breathe
wait a minute did she need the spacesuit
to breathe because she's been running
around this place with no spacesuit the
entire time what the hell is the meaning
of this also how did the insta spacesuit
know to cover everything except the
laser skates are they working despite
being inside the spacesuit boots
that's not how fire works Jupiter and
Caine obviously get on the ship at the
last second which is excellent timing
now the movies going to waste time
trying to make us think they didn't you
know suits look pretty Star Trek into
dolphin it I'm sure no one will ever see
this or be curious about it that ain't
bad either well they're a little creepy
and they probably complicate pegging I
taste you can I'm just I sure hope this
means it's over now okay
earlier we were told Chicago wouldn't
know that huge battle happened because
the aliens could erase people's memories
but what kind of power to Jupiter and
Cain have to do the same thing because
they don't have that power and they were
shot down by the military five seconds
later
yeah yeah yeah can you read my mind how
about getting victim into heaven what do
you mean why not I don't know why not my
hands okay thank you a new jail I have
to warn you I've heard relationships
based on intense experiences never work
okay
we'll have to base it on sex then
whatever you say ma'am I was told of the
house of abrasax seeded the earth III
didn't ask for a Santana
Abraxas I didn't listen to Santana
Abraxas I didn't do anything
it comes from people you're gonna tell
them
Charlotte breed is people Houston I have
a bad feeling about this mission please
expand okay let me tell you a story I
will fight him
oh so much I'm doing everything hold on